Otherwise, if
>> Oh, were we not recording today?
>> I think probably someone else joined
with a noteaker or something.
>> Awesome.
>> Yeah. Um, if we do this then now the
transaction is actually going to
continue and I can go do dupes. Now,
this might also be kind of annoying. So,
I'll do the dumb thing and I'll just say
like TXNS equals
get TXNS
without
dupes. I'll just pass in the old TXNS
and the new TXNS. pass through the
model, give it context that these are
coming from some new pages that might
have overlaps from the previous page and
then get out a new full array from the
model
and now we have our answer.
>> Um, and this is only if I actually
continued from a previous page. Uh,
otherwise I wouldn't do it. Uh,
otherwise I would just append everything
all there on its own. And now I' have
built a pipeline that is pretty good at
extracting all this data.
Um, before I get into it, any questions
for people uh, as we're doing this? Does
this kind of make sense? Like the
process that we went through of all the
way originally trying the PDF raw didn't
work. Figuring out how to go do that.
Well, we're going to apply some filters
and only find pages with actual
transactions for every single subsequent
step. Then we're going to go ahead and
solve the biggest problem, which is
headers and footers. Get rid of that.
And then we're going to solve the next
big problem, which is data breaking,
having page breaks. and continuing that
down with a similar problem where I just
ask an LLM, do these pages have
continued data or break points? If the
LM says yes, I do some special stuff
like merge the image into a new image or
paste both images in.
>> Yeah, I mean this approach makes sense.
Um, I'm trying to restrain like the
receptive field of of an LLM basically.
>> Um,
>> I'm just wondering if like there are
pretty good OCR models that do bounding
box detection. Um, so would like
would it make sense to
restrain the field even more just by
using a bounding box of the line item
instead of trying to like do this the
this page magic?
You can try that. In general, what I
have seen with bounding box models is
that they're generally worse than LLMs
at a lot of things. Um, so like it's the
same as like using an OCR model instead
of an LLM. On average, you're probably
right. It might work, but like what I
have seen in practice that the LM just
does a much better job. I think LM can
do more than you think. Um, but they
just need a little bit more stability to
help with them. So like if we get rid of
all the transaction data, I think that
like you you're definitely right. you
will get that transaction pulled out.
But I have found very very few bounding
box algorithm that'll actually detect
like every single bounding box on this
correctly because the semantic meaning
of a bounding box here is very
different. The semantic meaning of a
bounding box here is like this whole
thing.
Good luck getting a bounding box to give
you that shape.
That's just not going to work. What the
batting box algorithm will do is they'll
give you this one and it'll give you
this maybe if you're lucky and then I'll
give you this
and then I'll give you this
and now you're still stuck in a world of
pain of connecting all this stuff
together and that is a really really
really really hard problem. This is why
I think the math approach didn't really
work and why like training models end to
end would ended up being the answer
because the math approach would connect
all these together. Can you do this?
Yes.
It will just take more time, more tuning
and more correctness to go do this
>> and it will work on a less diverse set
of data and inputs. The reason that I
shared the header technique is not
because I think that's one of the best
techniques, but because there's a level
of standardization that I know is true
in headers,
it's like almost definitively true in
headers.
>> And so why not give yourself the extra
1% by just forcing the model to ignore
everything there basically.
>> Exactly. And this is only after finding
out that like in in the case of
financial data like headers are like a
big problem. In the case of medical
records, headers are a big problem. uh
the model just gets like confused by a
bunch of like numbers and stuff at the
bottom. Uh is kind of what we found.
It's like like these numbers end up
hurting the model's performance a lot
more. Uh passing in a page like this
hurts the model's performance a lot
more. So like just like
removing extra context from the model
does help that it doesn't need for sure,
but I also don't want to accidentally be
stuck in a world of pain where I have to
go and find all these weird edge cases
myself. I want to do the simplest thing
that takes almost no code that I can go
vibe code up that gives me that 1%. It's
a time to ROI problem over everything
else. Does that answer the question, AJ?
>> Yeah, it does. Cool. No, that makes
sense. Thanks.
>> Yeah, of course. Uh VJ, you got a
question?
>> Yeah, I I had a similar scenario
previously when we were processing
invoices. Yeah,
>> this is pre-LM days when we were all
building RPA boards and automations and
stuff.
>> So, we had different uh invoices coming
in from different vendors and we were
trying to build these automation
pipelines
uh and as as you can imagine like a
large enterprise has so many vendors and
each vendor might have their own format
for invoice and headers and stuff and
they have their own different sizes. So
what we ended up doing is we we again
took the uh paro principle there. We
took around 80% of the uh invoices which
had like five or six formats and try to
automate that another another 20%
uh sort of either now you could say
those are human in the loop but those
are processed manually.
uh I think that approach might be
applicable here as well where let's
let's imagine if you have a repo of a
million records historically you want to
process your entire data bank then uh
then I think you'll have to adapt these
pipelines using that uh uh approach as
well correct exactly so what I would do
if I really building this pipeline out
from like scratch on my own is I
actually wouldn't build headers and
footers out on every single process what
I would do is I would just save this per
type of vendor that's coming in. Do a
quick extraction of like what vendor is
this like Chase, US Bank or like the top
500 banks that exist.
save PDFs
together
and just like have that saved forever
and then literally every single week
pull one% of my pipeline through this
script to see if the header changes
dramatically and if it does put a human
in the loop in that process and then
once I put a human in the loop in that
process I will basically just go ahead
and um solve um like validate the data
that it's doing is not randomly a header
and footer because it's financial data,
I don't accidentally want to lose
something critical.
And that's kind of how I would solve
this problem like more long term. I do a
hybrid of exactly what you were
repeating, Vay, which is like specialize
for
um specialize for um specific vendors
and as much as possible and then the
other 90% just get slightly worse
quality or other 10% get slightly worse
quality.
>> Correct.
Everyone that's listening should 100% do
that for as much of their pipelines as
they can. It's like you drive really
high quality for u certain vendors that
you know are well understood and like
represent 80 to 90% of your data and
like sacrifice some lower quality on
10%. You have to understand that as a
part of building your AI pipeline.
um
>> where sorry if I can have a follow-up
question where I have difficulty in
extracting since we are talking about
multimodality
uh is extracting legal clauses for
example I have a use case where I'm
building uh extracting contracts like
vendor contracts vendor clauses those
are so random and they're defined per
use case per vendor one vendor can have
100 contracts which with you know
different contexts
So it's so complex to extract these
legal clauses that uh the the I mean
writing EAS for that is is just a
nightmare for me. What I would recommend
for a scenario like um abstract
scenarios like legal clauses where it's
not even concrete what is a legal clause
or not is I would honestly just go and
write take 50 documents and by hand pull
out what you would want to pull out and
then see if you can semantically
understand them. So I think a similar
problem that we worked with a company on
was around SEC violations like detect
SEC violations from like emails. That's
a really
>> this was our uh policy to prompts
episode that was like the example we did
>> right.
>> And the thing is like instead of trying
to solve all of SEC in one prompt
because models can't do that today maybe
they can tomorrow but not today. Um
we'll pick one policy and we'll make it
work on that. Then we'll pick another
policy make it work on that. It's
exactly the same as an invoice problem
where you instead of specializing per
vendor, we take the general thing of
legal clause and we break it down to
specialized clauses and we get really
high performance on those specialized
clauses and we plan that out. So you
could manually do something. Let me vib
I think this is building a little bit
but let me know if this sounds crazy is
you could do something like take 50 to
100 like legal clauses that you know
turn them into kind of like almost like
their own classification sets with
really good descriptions. Have the LLM
try to categorize into one of those
hundred. If it can't do it, it goes into
the other category. It goes into your
manual queue to go, "Oh, this is belongs
in this category. we need to change the
prompt for that category or this doesn't
belong in any category, we need to make
a new category. And like that you can
kind of build up where like even if the
wording is slightly different, if
semantically it fits into one of your
hundred categories, then you have a
solution. Does that sound accurate?
>> Dexter has basically become the ultimate
to value translator.
A lot of words and Dexter says a lot of
more better words and it's much better I
say. Uh um I'll take one more question
and then I think we're going to hop out
for today. Um sadly can't go the full 90
minutes, but if you post a question in
Discord, we'll get to it by the end of
the day.
>> Also, for the for the record, this show
runs an hour, so every minute after
after 60 minutes. Uh you're welcome. Uh
but thank you for bringing good
questions. This has been super fun. Um
yeah, Andre, you want to take us out
with the last one?
>> Yeah, really interesting techniques with
cropping. So I'll tell you how I've done
this with um medical records. So I I do
the OCR and then just extract the text
and the the OCR is pretty accurate um
for the text and then I pass the
language model both the text from the
OCR and attach the PDF and for medical
records that just seems to work and it
might work for for bank statements too.
Um but you would have to dduplicate
things probably and check with your
technique.
>> Yeah, exactly. Yeah,
>> exactly. That that's um yeah, this
technique with OCR, we found the same
thing for a lot of medical companies.
They do OCR first, but what they found,
what we found is actually every company
that was doing that has now stopped
doing that. They just pass the data
directly to the model with no OCR in the
middle and it actually works better.
>> Nice.
>> So, I would try that in the more newer
models and see if you get better results
and report back. We'd love to hear and
see if that works for you as well.
>> Thanks. Good stuff.
>> Cool. Would that